nous sommes à mumbai en inde dans un
centre d'appel où se déroulent des
activités frauduleuses
ils sont des dizaines à travailler le
soir pour rejoindre les occidentaux
durant jours objectif faire peur et
quand la victime résiste menacé france
bouffard a reçu ce genre d'appel highco
titre with many qui a accompagné le pas
de porte de sortie de poids comme
facilement elle n'est pas la seule la
fraude du soutien informatique a fait
perdre près d'un million de dollars aux
canadiens en 2018
microsoft reçoit 11 mille plaintes
chaque mois pour ce type de fraude de
partout dans le monde et chez eux cela
manque la grande portée de ces réseaux
criminels
elle la nécessité d'une coordination
internationale depuis cinq ans microsoft
contre attaque en fournissant des
renseignements aux forces policières de
nombreux pays dont le canada
ce qui donne des résultats l'an dernier
grâce aux renseignements de microsoft la
police indienne a frappé 30 centres
d'appels et arrêté 69 personnes cela
s'ajoute à d'autres arrestations qui ont
aussi eu lieu en inde en lien avec une
autre fronde celle de l' agence du
revenu du canada depuis que ses enfants
étaient fermés les plaintes en commun
diminué au noble
puis le volume qu'on avait les procès
même période la grc espère présenter
bientôt les résultats de l' enquête
octavia sur des ramifications de ces
organisations criminelles au canada
ici françois sence radio-canada à
montréal